you've inspected the door the door I'm
comfortable here is gonna stay here look
brother called earlier did you just push
the stick Oh get it still go and pick it
up I don't want the dog just go eat it
nothing happened you just need to go in
and think of the flashlight oh you're in
the room even the flashlight I do I
think it's a slash ok doctor again see
what I oh no no no okay yeah it ah no
gouge it out no no I like oh I know I
know I know I'm not doing I'm not doing
it oh my god that I know
this is your old water yeah pretty top
of it down hello oh crap I I know this
trick down I'm here this is pure sunhill
style again someone's good kind the open
the soccer oh oh god laughs it into pit
okay well that was unexpected I don't
write don't move
just that new just I knew haha I really
don't like this oh these noises gonna be
my dream site terribly hard time
splashing up in Detroit ah happening
again oh I wouldn't grab someone just
grab the air around me what we do now oh
the phone sorry so you're like all the
phones ringing about you it's burning
then just give up to we had the chosen
one so that was in context oh you can
chose it that wasn't showing for the
phone down some open-ended I don't know
if it was i'm gay i'm reading too much
into everything we we do it clinton game
over can we stop did I know that's far
too easy does it start again because
that's not happening well I notice right
don't you open the door is she there
we've just created this do this again we
got Paul Minn what am i getting you in
she pulled me in she totally yes you
understood why you don't want to step
out the door hi na crouching then she'll
hold me into the rain
hope you die